et bien aujourd'hui je suis venue en
corse pour parler de notre projet de
développement de l'île c'est un projet
qui répond aux vraies problématiques des
corses c'est problèmes que les corses
voudrait que l'état les aide à résoudre
[Musique]
donc on respecte les corses et toute la
différence entre valérie pécresse et
emmanuel macron parce qu emmanuel
paquereau n'a tenu aucune de ses
promesses parce qu'il a traité les
corses avec beaucoup de mépris
aujourd'hui
un pacte de confiance mais une chose est
certaine c'est que la méthode et presse
elle a rien à voir à la méthode macron
qu'était méthodes méprisant c'est une
méthode de respect et ce sera il réside
tendre à réellement la main aux forces
fait toute la différence
[Musique]